on a littéralement un certain nombre
d'états occidentaux sans doute les états
unis ont littéralement jeté la russie
dans les bras de la chine et le problème
aujourd'hui c'est de faire marche
arrière et ça va être extrêmement
difficile notamment parce que les sommes
nous autres occidentaux européens en
particulier et là je dis que la jeune
affirme que c'est une position en tout
cas que je soutiens personnellement il
est extrêmement importante on est très
très exigeant en termes de
demain donc c'est peut-être vous
surprendre si nous fait l'amitié de
meilleures idées m'entendre je pense que
ça doit pas être là constant permanent
des prises de décisions jeu politique
mais en tout cas ça doit toujours rester
une variable de prise de décision
seulement quand on s'intéresse aux
droits de l'homme par définition et
qu'on considère qu'ils ne sont pas
respectées dans un pays bas ont s'ingère
dans les affaires du pays et là on a
aussi outre les questions énergétiques
économique que stratégique à penser à
certains égards en asie centrale et ça a
été ça a été bien dit on a aussi un
intérêt commun en quelque sorte entre
moscou et pékin à ce que les occidentaux
pardonnez moi l'expression ne faut pas
leur nez dans les affaires intérieures
et le et le soul a dissous le hula la
politique affirmant près tout prétendant
affirmé le reste le sacro saint respect
de la souveraineté des états incluse
d'ailleurs dans la charte des nations
unies il faut bien le reconnaître mais
mais néanmoins remise en cause dans une
certaine mesure par d'autres textes tout
aussi important en matière de droit
international
donc la russie et la chine aujourd'hui
sont sont vent debout contre toute
interventionnisme mais pis y compris
d'ailleurs lorsqu'il est lorsqu'il émane
des ong ou lorsqu'il émane de deux
personnalités ou d'associations qui ne
sont pas inféodés 1 à washington à paris
alors que sais-je encore bon donc là
aussi ça soude en quelque sorte les deux
les deux diplomaties
[Musique]